Thank you for listening to The Rest Is History. For weekly bonus episodes, ad-free listening, early access to series, and membership of our much-loved chat community, go to therestishistory.com and join the club. That is therestishistory.com. What a disappointment this century has been. We have seen in every country a dissolution, a weakening of those bonds, a challenge to those principles, a decay of faith, an abridgment of hope, on which structure and ultimate existence of civilized society depends. We have seen in every part of the globe one great
感谢您收听《历史的余烬》。如果您想收听每周的独家加更节目、无广告广播、抢先体验系列节目，并加入我们备受喜爱的聊天社区，请访问 therestishistory.com 并加入俱乐部。网址是 therestishistory.com。这个世纪真是太令人失望了。我们在每个国家都看到了那些纽带的解体和削弱、对那些原则的挑战、信仰的衰落、希望的缩减，文明社会的结构和最终生存正是依赖于这些。我们在全球各地都看到一个伟大
country after another which had erected an orderly, peaceful, and prosperous structure of civilized society relapsing in hideous succession into bankruptcy, barbarism, or anarchy. Can you doubt, my faithful friends, as you survey this somber panorama, that mankind is passing through a period marked not only by an enormous destruction and abridgment of human species, not only by a vast impoverishment and reduction in means of existence, but also the destructive tendencies have not yet run their course, and only intense, concerted, and prolonged efforts, among all nations, can avert further and perhaps even greater calamities. Tom Holland, who is that?
的国家接着另一个国家，它们曾建立起文明社会井然有序、和平且繁荣的结构，却在一连串可怕的打击中退化为破产、野蛮或无政府状态。我的忠实朋友们，当你们审视这幅阴暗的全景图时，难道你们会怀疑，人类正在经历的这个时期，不仅伴随着人类物种的大规模消灭与减少，不仅伴随着生存资料的极大贫困化和缩减，而且那些破坏性趋势尚未走到尽头，只有所有国家进行紧张、一致和持久的努力，才能避免进一步乃至更大的灾难吗？汤姆·霍兰，那是谁？
Well, it's not Liam Neeson. It's not. You know perfectly well who that is. I think, considering the amount of grief you gave me over my very, very good impersonation of Liam Neeson. If you're telling me that that was Churchill. That was Winston Churchill. I will believe you. Addressing the electors of Dundee in 1922. Give me my Dundee cake.
好吧，这不是利亚姆·尼森。不是。你心里清楚那是谁。我想，考虑到你之前对我的那个非常、非常棒的利亚姆·尼森模仿秀进行了百般挑剔。如果你告诉我那是丘吉尔。那是温斯顿·丘吉尔。我会相信你的。这是他在 1922 年对邓迪选民的演讲。把我的邓迪蛋糕给我。
Where is my Dundee cake? And he came forth, didn he he did come forth he came forth and he was beaten by a man called edwin scrimgeour who is the only person ever to have won a seat in parliament standing for the scottish prohibition party so what banning alcohol yeah so that tells you just how that's how highly the scottish voters thought of winston churchill um they're prepared to elevate mr scrimgeour in his place well scotts have a long history of banning things that are fun they do christmas they didn't do christmas as we discovered in hogmanay this year yeah well yes that's true so um so yes
我的邓迪蛋糕在哪里？他站了出来，不是吗？他确实站出来了，他站出来结果被一个叫埃德温·斯克里姆杰（Edwin Scrymgeour）的人击败了，他是唯一一个代表苏格兰禁酒党（Scottish Prohibition Party）赢得议会席位的人。所以那是禁酒，是啊，所以这说明苏格兰选民对温斯顿·丘吉尔的看法有多高……嗯，他们准备让斯克里姆杰先生取代他的位置。好吧，苏格兰人长期以来都有禁止有趣事物的历史。他们有圣诞节，他们没有过圣诞节，正如我们在今年的霍格马纳（Hogmanay）发现的那样。是啊，好吧，是的，那是真的。所以……所以是的，
we're in 1922 aren't we um we should come back to churchill in a little bit that's i mean you know i probably won't do another impersonation but that gives you a flavor it's almost like you're back in 1922 standing on the streets of dundee a flavor of what was lost are you telling me that that wasn't actually audio footage when i was denied dominic when i was so cruelly denied the part of paddington as regular listeners will know well well dominicic, on that theme, could I just interrupt at this point? Because people who've listened to a lot of the podcasts will know that you missed out on the chance to play Paddington. Yeah. Because this was on the back of, so the director of Paddington directed you in Edinburgh.
我们身处 1922 年，对吧？嗯，我们一会儿应该再谈谈丘吉尔。我的意思是，你知道，我可能不会再做模仿了，但那能让你感受到一种风味。几乎就像你回到了 1922 年，站在邓迪的街头，体味着失去的东西。你是说那实际上不是音频素材吗？当我被剥夺了……多米尼克，当我如此残忍地被剥夺了帕丁顿熊的角色时，正如老听众们所知……好吧，多米尼克，顺着这个话题，我此时能打断一下吗？因为听过很多播客的听众会知道，你错失了扮演帕丁顿熊的机会。是的。因为这是在……所以帕丁顿熊的导演在爱丁堡执导过你。
He did. In the mid-1990s. Playing Thomas Beckett. Yes, in Jean-Louis's play Beckett. Yeah. A tremendous performance. And the Scotsman came to see it, is that right? Gave us two stars. I think it was out of five. Well,
他确实执导过。在 20 世纪 90 年代中期。扮演托马斯·贝克特。是的，在让·安努伊（Jean Anouilh）的戏剧《贝克特》中。是的。一场精彩的演出。苏格兰人报来看了，是这样吗？给了我们两颗星。我想是五星满分中的两星。好吧，
Dominic, at this point I just have to print off the review. Hold on. Oh no, you're kidding me. Did he say two stars, Dominic? They did. Did he say the Scotsman gave you two stars? i believe they gave us two stars out of five didn't they no no they didn't and i'll tell you how i know this because uh rebecca stubbs friend of the show keen listener uh someone who very generously sponsored me to show her and her family around roman london in aid of my benefit yeah um she informed me just a couple of days ago that her husband was the producer of that of that show and he's kept the review
多米尼克，此时我不得不把这篇评论打印出来。等等。哦，不，你在开玩笑吧。他说了两颗星吗，多米尼克？他们确实给了。苏格兰人报真的说过给你两颗星吗？我相信他们给了我们五星中的两颗，对吧？不，不，他们没有。我来告诉你我是怎么知道这一点的，因为……丽贝卡·斯塔布斯（Rebecca Stubbs），节目的朋友、忠实听众，一个非常慷慨地赞助我和她的家人参观罗马伦敦以支持我的慈善演出的人，对……她几天前告诉我，她的丈夫就是那部剧的制作人，而且他还留着那篇评论。
well must be good then if you I can which I can now read and Dominic I'm afraid Scott Smith only gave you a single star oh one star in years to come the cast of Always Beckett will regale dinner guests about their
好吧，那如果……我可以……那我一定写得很好，而多米尼克，恐怕《苏格兰人报》只给了你一颗星。哦，一颗星。在未来的岁月里，《永恒的贝克特》剧组将向晚宴客人们津津乐道他们在
opening night at the 1995 Fringe they will tell of the stumbled lines, fumbled set changes, creaking chairs, creaking floors, creaking dialogue. Well, the dialogue's not happening.
1995 年艺穗节（Fringe）的开幕之夜。他们会讲述那些磕磕绊绊的台词、搞砸的布景更换、吱吱作响的椅子、吱吱作响的地板、吱吱作响的对话。好吧，对话根本没进行。
I mean, that's John Hanwee's fault, surely. Of the guitar that appeared in the third act. only to resound again as it hit the floor off stage in the fifth. Of the tourist who wandered in through an exit, followed 10 minutes later by a mime artiste in full makeup. Beckett is a complex play about conflict between Henry II and Thomas Beckettett between church and state norman and saxon honor and duty and this is the line that you remember teenage bishops in trainers rarely convey the authority of the church acting styles from brando to hoffman to woody allen work against intellectual cohesion i think it was probably brando a powerful performance from
我的意思是，这肯定是约翰·汉维（John Hanwee）的错。关于在第三幕中出现的吉他，
the central character of henry. Oh, come on. Could not rescue the play and only threw it off balance. He is a young man well endowed in many respects, but cannot be named since the programme gives no cast list. The age old conflict between valour and discretion, perhaps. The companies are from various universities and will no doubt become lawyers, doctors, scientists, journalists, but not, I venture, actors. Oh, dear.
仅仅是为了在第五幕它掉落到后台地板时再次发出巨响。关于那个从出口游荡进来的游客，10分钟后后面跟着一个化着全妆的哑剧演员。贝克特是一部复杂的戏剧，关于亨利二世与托马斯·贝克特之间的冲突，关于教会与国家、诺曼人和萨克逊人、荣誉与义务之间的冲突……而这就是你记住的台词：穿着运动鞋的少年主教们很少能传达出教会的权威，从马龙·白兰度到达斯汀·霍夫曼再到伍迪·艾伦的表演风格破坏了思想的连贯性。我想那大概是白兰度吧。来自亨利这个核心人物的强有力表演，
That was Douglas Young for the Scotsman. And he was right, wasn't he? Because you didn't become an actor. I didn't become an actor, but I don't think he's really, I don't think he really got it. The whole brilliant kind of subtle riff with the tourist and the trainers i think a lot of people would now say scottish arts criticism was going through quite dark days in the mid yeah well it's like virginia wolf isn't it or indeed the sporting life on ulysses yeah it's that's very
也无法拯救这部剧，反而让它失去了平衡。他是一个在各方面都很有天赋的年轻人，但由于节目单上没有演员表而无法具名。也许这就是勇气与谨慎之间历久弥新的冲突。这些剧团来自各个大学，毫无疑问以后会成为律师、医生、科学家、记者，但我敢说，不会成为演员。哦，天哪。
didn't get the point anyway listen we've blown massively off course there. What were we talking about? I can't remember. We were talking about, so we're about to talk about 1922. Yes. So yesterday when Tom Holland wasn't reading out disobliging reviews of top actors, we were talking about 1922, about modernism, about Bolshevism, the birth of Italian fascism and so on. And I mean, obviously one thing that was completely missing from yesterday's podcast, apart from you reading out
那是道格拉斯·杨（Douglas Young）为《苏格兰人报》写的。而他是对的，不是吗？因为你没有成为演员。我没有成为演员，但我不认为他真的……我不认为他真的看懂了。那种带有游客和运动鞋的精彩而微妙的讽刺，我想现在很多人会说，苏格兰的艺术评论在当时正经历着相当黑暗的日子……嗯，这就像弗吉尼亚·伍尔夫，不是吗？或者确实像《生活》杂志对《尤利西斯》的评价一样。那真是……
ridiculously ill-judged notices in Scottish newspapers, was America. And in a weird way, America is politically... Kind of impotent, isn't it? It is. It's kind of turned inwards. It's not joined the League of Nations. the press was an american initiative woodrow wilson but basically other americans don't want to join it so they've they've rejected his idea the president is now called warren harding who is just very bland and and boring republican he's a bit corrupt
反正没抓到重点。听着，我们严重偏离正题了。我们刚才在说什么？我不记得了。我们在谈论……所以我们正要谈论 1922 年。是的。所以昨天，当汤姆·霍兰不在宣读对顶级演员那些不讨喜的评论时，我们在谈论 1922 年，关于现代主义、布尔什维克主义、意大利法西斯的诞生等等。我的意思是，显然昨天的播客中完全缺失的一点——除了你宣读苏格兰报纸上那些极其不明智的评论之外——就是美国。而在某种诡异的方式下，美国在政治上是……某种程度上是无能的，对吧？确实如此。它有点转向内部了。它没有加入国际联盟。
i mean his big thing is he promises a return to normalcy after the sounds familiar yeah well i mean. Well, I mean, he's a man who basically makes no impact at all on the international stage. And that's partly by design, because America is obviously isolationist in the 20s. And actually, the things that, looking from outside, are really striking is obviously prohibition. I mean, we mentioned Churchill losing. So prohibition has been underway since the beginning of the decade.
国际联盟是美国的倡议，由伍德罗·威尔逊发起，但基本上其他美国人都拒绝加入它，所以他们否定了他的想法。现在的总统叫沃伦·哈丁，他只是一个非常温和、无聊的共和党人，还有点腐败。
And also the support for the Ku Klux Klan, which is extraordinary. So the Ku Klux Klan has revived after D.W. Griffith's birth of a nation. And we talked yesterday about the sort of paramilitary violence of the early 20s. And I think the Klan is America's equivalent of that. So it's got about a million members. Right. So that's massively about a million members. Right. So that's massively influenced by a Hollywood film. Yeah.
我的意思是，他最大的特点是承诺在战后……听起来很熟悉，对吧？嗯，我的意思是……我的意思是，他基本上是一个在国际舞台上毫无影响力的政治人物。这在某种程度上是刻意为之的，因为美国在 20 世纪 20 年代显然奉行孤立主义。事实上，从外部看，真正引人注目的事情显然是禁酒令。我的意思是，我们提到了丘吉尔落选。因此，禁酒令从这个十年代初就开始实施了。
And film, I suppose, is the big thing, isn't it? And I guess what you'd say is that America is maybe politically, you know, it's retreated from the stage. But this is the age where popular culture it's it's america is for the first time absolutely the popular flavor of the month i think so this is the jazz age yeah you get to talk about americanization people talking about the americanization of the world and hollywood as you say um so it's interesting actually when you look at 1922 a lot three very significant firsts well i mean there, three very significant firsts. Well, I mean, there are lots of significant firsts,
还有对三K党（Ku Klux Klan）的支持，这太不可思议了。三K党在 D·W·格里菲斯（D.W. Griffith）的《一个国家的诞生》（The Birth of a Nation）之后复活了。我们昨天讨论了 20 世纪 20 年代初的那种准军事暴力，我认为三K党就是美国的同类产物。所以它大约有一百万会员。对。所以这在很大程度上……大约有一百万会员。对。所以这在很大程度上受到了好莱坞电影的影响。是的。
but Charlie Chaplin moves into feature films from doing the short films he'd done earlier. Charlie Chaplin is the most famous man in the world, isn't he? He probably is. Yeah, I think he probably is. So he has joined up with Douglas Fairbanks and Mary Pickford to form their own kind of studio. He wants to move into serious feature films, but you also have Walt Disney
而电影，我想，是最大的事情，对吧？我想你会说，美国在政治上可能……你知道，它从舞台上退缩了。但这是大众文化……美国第一次绝对成为最受欢迎的潮流的时代。我想是的，这是爵士时代。是的，你开始听到人们谈论美国的现代化、人们谈论世界的美国化以及正如你所说的好莱坞……所以实际上很有趣，当你审视 1922 年时，有三个非常重要的“第一”……好吧，我的意思是，
doing his first animated films. Hitchcock in England. So Hitchcock does a film called, I think called Number 13 that is now completely lost. But you see... But you say Disney is probably the biggest of those. Disney is the huge thing.
有很多重要的“第一”，但查理·卓别林从他早期拍摄的短片转向了故事片。查理·卓别林是世界上最著名的人，不是吗？他大概是的。是的，我想他大概是的。所以他与道格拉斯·费尔班克斯（Douglas Fairbanks）和玛丽·皮克福德（Mary Pickford）联合成立了自己的制片厂。他想转向严肃的故事片，但你同时也有华特·迪士尼
Because Little Red Riding Hood is the first, but you've got Cinderella coming out at the end of the year. And also you've got the kind of escalating expense on blockbusters. You mentioned Griffiths, who then from Birth of a Nation went on to make Intolerance.
制作他的第一批动画片。还有在英国的希区柯克。所以希区柯克拍了一部电影，我想叫《第 13 号》（Number 13），现在已经完全失传了。但你看……但你说迪士尼可能是其中规模最大的。迪士尼是一件大事。
But then Intolerance gets lapped in this year by Robin Hood, made by Douglas Fairbanks, which is the most, I think, I mean, by far the most expensive film. Almost one and a half million dollars, I think. And you know what's a fascinating thing about, so Robin Hood is the first film to be given a proper Los Angeles premiere. And the name of the... Do you know the name of the cinema, Tom? It would appeal to you because it would allow you to talk about something that I know you're very interested in.
因为《小红帽》是第一部，但年底你将迎来《灰姑娘》的上映。而且你还有大制作电影成本不断攀升的现象。你提到了格里菲斯，他接着《一个国家的诞生》之后去拍摄了《党同伐异》（Intolerance）。
The cinema is Grauman's Egyptian Theatre. And interestingly, that is a month before something very close to your heart. Discoverers, which is, in a way, I mean, purely as a news story. So as something to get people talking that isn't, you know, about high politics or whatever. You'd say the biggest of those kind of news stories, possibly of the century, happens in 1922, which is the discovery of the tomb of those kind of news stories possibly of the century happens in 1922 which is the discovery of the tomb of Tutankhamen
但随后《党同伐异》在这一年被由道格拉斯·费尔班克斯制作的《罗宾汉》（Robin Hood）所超越，我认为这是……我的意思是，可以说是迄今为止最昂贵的电影。我想大约有一百五十万美元。你知道关于……的一件极其有趣的事情是什么吗？《罗宾汉》是第一部举行正式的洛杉矶首映式的电影。而那个……你知道电影院的名字吗，汤姆？这会吸引你，因为它能让你谈论一些我知道你非常感兴趣的事情。
yeah biggest news story of the century that's a very big claim so it established so craze is a word that is first used
这家电影院是格劳曼埃及剧院（Grauman's Egyptian Theatre）。有趣的是，这发生在你非常关心的某件事的一个月前。发现者，这在某种程度上，纯粹作为一个新闻故事——作为一个能让人们谈论的、不是关于高层政治或诸如此类事情的话题——你会说，这类新闻故事中最大的一起，可能也是这个世纪最大的新闻故事，发生在 1922 年，那就是……这类新闻故事中最大的一起，可能也是这个世纪最大的新闻故事，发生在 1922 年，那就是图坦卡蒙陵墓的发现。
in the 20s the archetype of the craze is kind of tutmania which is generated by discovery of
是的，本世纪最大新闻故事，这个说法分量很重。所以它确立了……“狂热”（craze）这个词是
by Howard Carter november 1922 of the first and only intact pharaonic tomb ever to be found so full of wonderful things as yeah carter didn't actually say but his ghost writer made him say so uh you know we talked about this in the akhenaten episode but cut it's incredible story. Carter had been toiling away for years and years and years on behalf of his patron, Lord Carnarvon. And he goes into the summer of 1920, the digging season of 1922, and it's the last chance saloon. You know, Carnarvon's going to withdraw the funding after this and on the 4th of november they discover a step and carter's been looking for tootin carmen's tomb and they clear away the step and by the 6th of november it's clear that carter has discovered what he what he's been looking for and of course he can't go straight in because he has to wait for lord canarvon. He wires Lord Carnarvon and Carnarvon wires back, possibly come soon.
在 20 年代首次被广泛使用的，“狂热”的原型就是由……所引发的“图坦卡蒙狂热”。由霍华德·卡特（Howard Carter）于 1922 年 11 月发现了有史以来第一座也是唯一一座完好无缺的法老陵墓，里面装满了美妙的东西，正如……卡特实际上并没有这么说，但他的代笔作家让他这么说了。所以……你知道，我们在阿肯纳顿那一集中讨论过这个，但卡特这是一个难以置信的故事。卡特为了他的赞助人卡那封勋爵（Lord Carnarvon），辛辛苦苦地劳作了整整好多年。然后他迎来了 1920 年的夏天，1922 年的挖掘季，这是最后一搏了。你知道，卡那封在这之后就要撤回资金了，而在 11 月 4 日，他们发现了一级台阶，卡特一直在寻找图坦卡蒙的陵墓，他们清理了台阶，到 11 月 6 日，很明显卡特已经发现了……他一直在寻找的东西。当然，他不能直接进去，因为他必须等待卡那封勋爵。他给卡那封勋爵拍了电报，卡那封回电说，可能会尽快赶来。
Oh no. She'd think, no, get here. And Carnarvon very rapidly realises exactly what it is that Carter's found and what he means. So they zip over. And so the 26th of November, they enter the tomb. You know, can you see things? Wonderful things.
哦，不。你会想，不，马上过来。卡那封非常迅速地意识到了卡特发现的究竟是什么以及这意味着什么。于是他们飞奔过去。所以在 11 月 26 日，他们进入了陵墓。你知道，你能看到东西吗？美妙的东西。
A gleam of gold. They know that they've found it. And on the 30th of November, the news is splashed in the Times. So it's exclusive for them. And the world goes mad for it. Yeah, in his book we were talking about last time, Constellation of Genius, Kevin Jackson's book about the events of 1922, he says,
金色的微光。他们知道他们找到了。而在 11 月 30 日，这个消息登上了《泰晤士报》的头版。所以这是他们的独家新闻。全世界都为之疯狂。是的，正如他在我们上次讨论的那本书《天才星座》（Constellation of Genius，凯文·杰克逊关于 1922 年事件的书）中所说的那样，
doesn't he say that the opening of Tutankhamen's tomb is basically the first mass media world event? That's what I was struggling to articulate. And I suppose it does start this sort of Egyptian mania, doesn't it? And I suppose it also, what it reflects, though, is that technologically you can have mass media world events. Absolutely, yes. And you know who gets elbowed out of it? I don't uh from the press
难道他没有说过图坦卡蒙陵墓的开启基本上是第一场大众传媒的世界事件吗？这就是我刚才极力想表达的。我想它确实开启了这种埃及狂热，不是吗？我想它也反映出的一点是，在技术上你可以拥有大众传媒的世界事件了。绝对是这样的，是的。你知道谁被挤出去了吗？我不知道……从新闻
coverage um is a guy called arthur agle who is being employed by the daily mail wow the newspaper that we discovered last time created modernism yes but also the daily mail creates the legend of the curse because arthur agle is so furious at not being allowed exclusive access to the tomb that he comes up with this idea after Lord Carnarvon dies that he's been felled by the curse. So another triumph. Well, you know what also the Daily Mail also created, which is a huge part of the culture of 1922. And in some ways, you could argue the year's most lasting and important legacy radio right so tell us about radio dominic so you know people have been experimenting with radio broadcasts and whatnot um for years um the key person in britain is a man called marconi
报道中……有一个叫阿瑟·韦格尔（Arthur Weigall）的人，他当时受雇于《每日邮报》。哇，我们上次发现创造了现代主义的报纸，是的，但《每日邮报》也创造了诅咒的传奇，因为阿瑟·韦格尔对未能获得陵墓的独家采访权感到非常愤怒，以至于在卡那封勋爵死后，他想出了这个主意，宣称他是被诅咒击倒的。又一个胜利。好吧，你知道《每日邮报》还创造了什么吗？这是 1922 年文化中极其重要的一部分。在某些方面，你甚至可以说是这一年最持久、最重要的遗产：无线电。对，那么给我们讲讲无线电吧，多米尼克。你知道，人们一直在试验无线电广播之类的东西……多年来，在英国的关键人物是一个名叫马 Marconi（马可尼）的人，
who set up the marconi company who's obviously obviously an Italian immigrant. And in 1920, he gets sponsorship from the Daily Mail to do the first live entertainment broadcast, which is done by Dame Nellie Melba. She sings the song, and the Marconi Company broadcast it. And this is one of their – the Daily Mail are hugely into stunts at the beginning of the 20s. So at one point, Lord Northcliffe invents a new hat, for example. And they're always trying all these different wheezes.
他创立了马可尼公司，显然他是一个意大利移民。1920 年，他得到了《每日邮报》的赞助，进行了第一次现场娱乐广播，由多莉·内利·梅尔巴（Dame Nellie Melba）演唱。她唱了一首歌，马可尼公司播出了它。这是他们的……《每日邮报》在 20 年代初非常热衷于各种噱头。所以在某个时候，诺思克利夫勋爵（Lord Northcliffe）发明了一种新帽子，例如。他们总是尝试各种不同的奇思妙想。
Why are they not doing that now? I think they probably are. I mean, I haven't invented a new hat for them, but give it time. Get on with it. But yeah, the Marconi Company, I mean, they're the real pioneers in Britain of radio. So it's in early 1922 i think it's um february actually 14th of february that you have the first regular broadcasts which
为什么他们现在不这么做了？我想他们可能在做吧。我的意思是，我还没有为他们发明一顶新帽子，但拭目以待吧。继续说吧。但是，是的，马可尼公司，我的意思是，他们是英国无线电真正的先驱。所以正是在 1922 年初，我想实际上是……嗯，2 月，实际上是 2 月 14 日，你迎来了第一次常规广播，
are from a hut which i've been to tom actually because i did a documentary about this for for the bbc because this is where the bbc comes from there there's a hut um in a place called rittle which is outside the marconi factory in chelmsford in essex and a man called peter eckersley would broadcast on tuesday evenings for half an hour and they were the first regular radio broadcasts in britain or in the world in britain now what's happened in america is that you have had this explosion of radio at exactly the same time. But in America, it's completely unregulated. So you have maybe 100 radio stations by the spring, and then in the summer, you have hundreds of radio stations in America.
来自一个棚屋——汤姆，我实际上去过那里，因为我曾为此为 BBC 制作过一部纪录片——因为这就是 BBC 的发源地。在埃塞克斯郡切姆斯福德的马可尼工厂外一个叫里特尔（Rittle）的地方，有一个棚屋，一个名叫彼得·埃克尔斯利（Peter Eckersley）的人会在星期二晚上广播半个小时，它们是英国乃至世界上最早的常规无线电广播。在英国。现在在美国发生的事情是，你在同一时间迎来了无线电的爆炸式增长。但在美国，它是完全不受监管的。所以到春天时你可能有一百家广播电台，然后到了夏天，美国就有数百家广播电台了。
Right. So it's like kind of internet startups. It's exactly that. It's exactly that. So lots of people have asked questions about, you know, what is the most important invention or discovery that is associated with the sort of modernity of the 20s? So Kevin Douglas asks about broadcasting. Chris Salmon says, which is the most important invention? And I would say the answer is radio, actually.
对，所以这就像某种互联网初创公司。完全是那样，完全是那样。所以很多人都提出了关于以下方面的问题：什么是与 20 年代现代性相关的最重要发明或发现？凯文·道格拉斯（Kevin Douglas）问到了广播。克里斯·萨尔蒙（Chris Salmon）问，哪项是最重要的发明？而我会说，答案其实是无线电。
And I think what's so interesting about it is in America, it is advertising funded, and there's this explosion of radio stations throughout the summer of 22. There's this sort of sense of chaos and free for all. And in Britain, the people observe this and they say, oh, my God, we can't have anything like this. This is an absolute sort of this would be the worst possible thing. And they actually say, you know, it's an anarchy. It's chaos and of course that we were talking last time about that the the absolute ubiquitous fear of anarchy and of bolshevism and all this kind of thing and the thirst for order
我认为它最有趣的地方在于，在美国，它是靠广告资助的，在 22 年的整个夏天，无线电台呈爆炸式增长。这里有一种混乱和自由竞争的感觉。而在英国，人们观察到了这一点，然后他们说，哦，天哪，我们绝不能允许发生这样的事情。这绝对是一种……这将是最糟糕的事情。他们实际上说，你知道，这是无政府状态。这是一场混乱。当然，我们上次还在讨论那种对无政府状态、对布尔什维克主义以及所有这类事情的普遍存在的恐惧，以及对秩序的渴望，
at the beginning of the 20s and i sort of wonder whether that's in in people's you know they have this hatred of disorder and of uncertainty under unsurprisingly after what they've been through and so the marconi company and and five of the other big companies get together and they want to set up a monopoly licensed by the government, which will be called the British Broadcasting Company. And that's what basically happens. And that's what happens.
在 20 年代初，我有点想知道这是否深深植根于人们的脑海中——经过了他们所经历的一切后，他们理所当然地对混乱和不确定性怀有一种厌恶。因此，马可尼公司和其他五家大公司聚在一起，他们想要建立一个由政府特许的垄断企业，它将被称为英国广播公司（British Broadcasting Company）。这基本上就是发生的事情。这就是所发生的一切。
So they get together. And by October, they have formed what becomes basically the BBC. And the BBC starts its first regular radio broadcast on the 14th of November 1922 and to basically to listen to them you need a radio set which I mean they're not cheap and you have to pay a 10 shilling license fee and the license fee right from the beginning yeah the license fee is there the license fee is there right from the beginning what isn't there right from the beginning is complaining about the license fee which comes in later right um but you know who um
所以他们聚到了一起。到 10 月份，他们组建了基本上演变成 BBC 的机构。BBC 于 1922 年 11 月 14 日开始了它的第一次常规无线电广播。基本上要想收听它们，你需要一台收音机，我的意思是，它们并不便宜，而且你必须支付 10 先令的执照费。许可证费从一开始就存在，是的，许可证费从一开始就存在，许可证费从一开始就存在。从一开始就不存在的是对许可证费的抱怨，那是后来才出现的。对……但是你知道谁……
who despises the bbc tom our old friend from the previous episode virginia wolf does she she does not believe in um she's horrified by the idea of bringing high culture to the masses because she said they won't understand it it'll destroy her culture it's not quite so wolf complains at one point that the bbc's first director of talks who is this pioneering extraordinary woman called hilda matheson uh wolf doesn't like her she says um there are two things wrong with her one she's got a wooden face right and the other virginia wolf's face famous yeah of course we're all people and then virginf says the other thing she doesn't like is that she lives in South Kensington.
谁鄙视 BBC，汤姆？我们上一集的旧友，弗吉尼亚·伍尔夫。她真的吗？她不相信……她对把高雅文化带给大众的想法感到惊恐，因为她说他们不会懂的，这会毁了她的文化。情况并非完全如此……伍尔夫在某个时候抱怨说，BBC 的第一任演讲总监——也就是这位开创性的、非凡的女性，名叫希尔达·马瑟森（Hilda Matheson）——伍尔夫不喜欢她，她说……她身上有两个毛病，第一，她长了一张木头脸，对吧？另一个……弗吉尼亚·伍尔夫的面孔很有名。是的，当然，我们所有人都是人。然后弗吉尼亚·伍尔夫说，她不喜欢的另一件事是她住在南肯辛顿。
The vulgarity. She regards as middle class, drab and dreary. Yeah. She's a cracker. Yeah, a lovely person. So, yeah, so from a British point of view, I would say that that's absolutely the most important thing about 22.
那种庸俗。她认为那是中产阶级的、单调乏味的、沉闷的。是的。她可真是个妙人。是的，一个可爱的人。所以，是的，从英国的角度来看，我认为这绝对是 22 年最重要的事情。
Did you read about the first drama broadcast on BBC? No, go on. It went out on Christmas Eve. Yeah. And it was called The Truth About Father Christmas.
你读过关于 BBC 第一部广播剧的报道吗？没有，快说。它是在平安夜播出的。是的。它的名字叫《关于圣诞老人的真相》（The Truth About Father Christmas）。
Oh my God. What a thing to put out on Christmas Eve. I know everyone's put away their Christmas decorations but a little festive, last final festive touch there.
哦，天哪。在平安夜播出这种东西。我知道大家都已经收起了圣诞装饰，但那里带有一点节日气氛，最后的节日触感。
That was the first ever BBC radio drama. Does it tell thebc what does it does it tell the real what's it say i don't know i don't know what it's about i'm guessing it's the truth about father christmas don't worry that's probably lost now maybe it's not maybe it's on bbc sounds with their unfair monopoly i don't think there's anything else on bbc sounds worth listening to tom don't think so certainly not. No, just stick to us. So anyway, 14th of November, 22, is the BBC's start broadcasting. And you know what happens on the 15th of November, Tom?
那是 BBC 有史以来的第一部广播剧。它告诉了我们……BBC 的……它告诉了……真实的情况是什么？我不知道，我不知道它是关于什么的。我猜它是关于圣诞老人的真相。别担心，那可能现在已经失散了。也许没有，也许它在 BBC Sounds（BBC 的音频平台）上，伴随着他们不公平的垄断。我认为 BBC Sounds 上没有什么其他值得聆听的东西了，汤姆。不觉得有。当然没有。不，还是听我们的吧。不管怎样，1922 年 11 月 14 日，BBC 开始广播。你知道 11 月 15 日发生了什么吗，汤姆？
No. General election. Ah. Very important general election. But we should come to that in a bit. We should talk about, because Britain is still kind of top nation in the 20s, isn't it? Well, are we? Well, this is the question.
不知道。大选。啊。非常重要的大选。但我们一会儿再谈这个。我们应该谈谈……因为英国在 20 年代仍然算得上是顶级强国，不是吗？嗯，我们是吗？这是一个问题。
Are we? This is the question. Because is it not a straw in the wind that a naval conference is held in Washington? Yeah, fair point. And it's the first attempt at arms control, an arms control treaty. Well, yeah, it's one of the first. But is this in the context of the dreadnoughts
我们是吗？这是一个问题。因为在华盛顿举行海军会议，难道不是风向标吗？是的，有道理。这是对军备控制、军备控制条约的第一次尝试。好吧，是的，这是第一次尝试之一。但这是否是在无畏舰
and everything in the arms, the naval race before the First World War between Britain and Germany? And it's an attempt to try and regulate the size of fleets. Yeah, it is. And Japan is kind of starting to muscle in. Exactly. So it's agreed that the balance of power will be Britain 5, US 5, Japan 3. So equal billing between Britain and the United States. And in effect, that draws a line under the many, many centuries of British naval supremacy.
以及第一次世界大战前英国和德国之间军备竞赛、海军竞赛的背景下进行的？这是试图规范舰队规模的一次尝试。是的，确实如此。而且日本开始挤进来了。正是如此。因此，人们商定力量平衡将是：英国 5，美国 5，日本 3。所以英国和美国享有同等地位。实际上，这就给长达好几个世纪的英国海上霸权画上了句号。
I think you're absolutely right. Because before the First World War, the British, the Royal Navy, it still operated what they called the two-power standard, which was… That they had to have twice the number of had to ships of the next two competitors exactly and that they had yeah exactly that they had to basically outmatch their their two biggest competitors and um they ditched that and as part of the washington naval treaty they agreed to scrap 24 ships that they're already planning to build capital ships so that's the point at which i think they they realize then then you know they're already planning to build, capital ships. So that's the point at which I think they realise that the Americans are going to overtake them.
我想你是绝对正确的。因为在第一次世界大战之前，英国皇家海军仍然实行他们所谓的“两强标准”（two-power standard），即……他们必须拥有的战舰数量是接下来两个竞争对手的两倍，这完全正确……并且他们必须……是的，完全正确，他们基本上必须压倒他们最大的两个竞争对手。他们抛弃了这一标准，作为华盛顿海军条约的一部分，他们同意废弃 24 艘他们已经计划建造的主力舰。所以这就是我认为他们意识到……当时他们已经计划建造主力舰了。所以这就是我认为他们意识到美国将超越他们的那个时间点。
Yeah, they're not going to compete in the same way. And is there a sense that that's okay because America is likely to be an ally? That's a good question. I don't know enough about it to... Possibly. Possibly. I think there's also a sense though of I mean they're
是的，他们不会以同样的方式竞争了。人们是否有一种感觉，这没关系，因为美国很可能会成为盟友？这是一个好问题。我对这方面的了解还不够深入……可能吧。可能吧。我想人们也有一种感觉……我的意思是，他们
desperately trying to cut spending at the beginning of the 20s so Lloyd George's government that's something called the Geddes axe which is all about cutting spending because they've obviously run up absolutely astronomical debt to pay for the First World War and I think there is a as you as you alluded
在 20 年代初拼命削减开支，劳合·乔治（Lloyd George）的政府推出了所谓的“ Geddes 斧”（Geddes Axe），这完全是为了削减开支，因为他们为了支付第一次世界大战的费用，显然背负了天文数字般的巨额债务。正如你所提到的，我认为存在着一个非常奇怪的悖论：一方面，如果你看地图，大英帝国几乎达到了其最大疆域。所以地图上的粉红色比以往任何时候都要多。但与此同时，这种收缩感已经存在了。嗯，而且联合王国（大不列颠及爱尔兰）的领土完整也不复存在了。是的，那是真的。事实上，这是这个故事中极其重要的一部分。自我们开播以来，我们在播客中完全没有谈论过的一件事就是爱尔兰。
to there is this really odd paradox that on the one hand, if you look at the map, the British Empire is pretty much at its greatest extent. So there's more pink on the map than ever before or since. But at the same time, there's already this sense of retrenchment. Well, and also that the territorial integrity of the United Kingdom, of Great Britain and Ireland, is no more. Yeah, that's right. And actually that's such a huge part of this story. And something we haven't talked about at all in this podcast since we started it is Ireland.
我们真的应该深入探讨一下，因为这是一个如此迷人又悲剧的故事。你觉得我们在谈论爱尔兰之前应该先休息一下吗，汤姆？是的，我们休息一下，然后回来讨论爱尔兰独立和内战。我是玛丽娜·海德。
And we should really go into it because it's such a sort of fascinating and tragic story. Do you think we should take a break before we get to Ireland, Tom? Yes, let's take a break and then we'll come back and we'll talk about Irish independence and the Civil War. I'm Marina Hyde.
我是理查德·奥斯曼。我们共同主持《历史就是娱乐》。这里有你每周必看的娱乐新闻、评论和一抹八卦。在我们的问答环节中，我们拉开娱乐行业的帷幕，告诉你这一切是如何运作的。我们刚刚启动了会员俱乐部。
And I'm Richard Osman. And together we host The Rest Is Entertainment. It's your weekly fix of entertainment news, reviews, splash of showbiz gossip. And on our Q&A, we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works. We have just launched our Members Club.
如果你想要无广告收听、独家加更节目和优先购买现场门票，请前往 therestisentertainment.com。网址是 therestisentertainment.com。空中那个高亢的声音是什么，那是母亲哀悼的呢喃？那些成群结队、戴着风帽、蜂拥掠过无际平原、在龟裂的大地上踉跄前行、四周唯有平坦地平线环绕的人是谁？山峦之上的那座城市是什么，它碎裂、重组并在紫色的空中炸裂？倾圮的高塔，耶路撒冷，雅典，亚历山大，维也纳，伦敦，虚幻。
If you want ad-free listening, bonus episodes and early access to live tickets, head to therestisentertainment.com. That's therestisentertainment.com. What is that sound high in the air, murmur of maternal lamentation? Who are those hooded hordes swarming over endless plains, stumbling in cracked earth, ringed by the flat horizon only? What is the city over the mountains, cracks and reforms and bursts in the violet air? Falling towers, Jerusalem, Athens, Alexandria, Vienna, London, unreal.
T·S·艾略特的《荒原》，我们在第一部分讨论过。只是指出你刚才没有用 T·S·艾略特的腔调读。我就说这么多。耶路撒冷，雅典，亚历山大，维也纳，伦敦，虚幻。哇。虚幻。哦，我真希望刚才没说那句话。当然，原因在于艾略特描绘的是一种秩序崩解的感觉，伟大的帝国秩序正在崩解，伟大的城市正在坍塌。
T.S. Eliot, The Wasteland, we talked about in the first part. Just pointed you didn't do it in T.S. Eliot's voice. That's all I'll say. Jerusalem, Athens, Alexandria, Vienna, London, unreal. Whoa. Unreal. Oh, I wish I hadn't said that now. The reason for that, of course, is that Eliot is writing about the sense of an order cracking, great imperial orders, great cities collapsing.
艾略特的《荒原》，我们在第一部分讨论过。只是指出你刚才没用艾略特的语气来读。我就说这么多。耶路撒冷，雅典，亚历山大，维也纳，伦敦，虚幻。哇。虚幻。哦，我真希望刚才没说过这话。当然，原因在于艾略特写的是一种秩序崩塌的感觉，伟大的帝国秩序，伟大的城市在崩溃。
And one of the areas of parts of the world where, and it must have informed that, where things are definitely imploding is the Levant. Great cities of Jerusalem, Athens and Alexandria are all embroiled in kind of convulsions in this year. But he also mentions London. Yeah. And on the 22nd of June in London, Eaton Square, to be precise, a field marshal called Sir Henry Wilson is shot.
而世界上那些局势绝对在内爆的地区之一，肯定也影响了这一点，那就是黎凡特。耶路撒冷、雅典和亚历山大这些伟大城市今年都卷入了某种动乱之中。但他也提到了伦敦。是的。在6月22日的伦敦，确切地说是在伊顿广场，一位名叫亨利·威尔逊爵士的元帅被枪杀。
And he's shot by two men who had served in the first world war in the great war. And one of them had actually lost a leg at Ypres. They shoot Sir Henry Wilson as he's coming back from opening a war memorial at Liverpool street railway station to the dead of the great war. And they shoot him because they are members of the ira yeah so they've been in the british army they're now in the irish republican army um and dominic this this assassination on the streets of london of a guy who was actually irish he was uh you know vehemently anti-home
他是被两个参加过第一次世界大战即伟大战争的人枪杀的。其中一人甚至在伊普尔失去了一条腿。他们枪杀亨利·威尔逊爵士时，他正从利物浦街火车站揭幕一个纪念第一次世界大战阵亡者的战争纪念碑回来。他们枪杀他是因为他们是爱尔兰共和军（IRA）的成员，对，所以他们曾加入英国军队，现在又加入了爱尔兰共和军。嗯，多米尼克，这次在伦敦街头发生的暗杀事件，受害者实际上是个爱尔兰人，他是个……你知道的，坚决反对地方自治
rule uh anti-irish independence anti-Irish independence. The Irish War of Independence had been going on. He was pressing the British government to carry on. He said that the truce that ended the Irish War of Independence was rank filthy cowardice. And it's unclear actually who was behind it. But it has a kind of knock-on effect, doesn't it? It does, absolutely. It's a landmark in British and Irish history,
的人，反对爱尔兰独立，反对爱尔兰独立。爱尔兰独立战争一直在进行。他一直在敦促英国政府继续打下去。他说，结束爱尔兰独立战争的休战协定是极度卑鄙的懦弱行为。而且实际上并不清楚是谁在幕后主使。但这产生了一种连锁反应，不是吗？确实如此，绝对是。这是英国和爱尔兰历史上的一个里程碑，
even though in Britain, pretty much nobody, I imagine, listening to this podcast will remember it. I mean, he's a massive figure. He's the Chief of the Imperial General Staff, Sir Henry Wilson. And the cabinet meets that night. They take the revolvers that had shot him, the police, and they put them on the cabinet table.
尽管在英国，我猜听这个播客的几乎没有人会记得它。我的意思是，他是一个极其重要的人物。他是帝国总参谋长，亨利·威尔逊爵士。内阁那天晚上召集开会。他们把枪杀他的左轮手枪拿来，警察拿来的，把它们放在了内阁桌子上。
And Lloyd George and Churchill look at these guns and they say, my God, you know, these are the guns that just an hour ago shot Sir Henry Wilson, who they both knew really well. And this is the trigger in some ways for the Irish Civil War. irish civil war right but it also exists in as a kind of full stop in the process of negotiation that had led to um ireland leaving the free state as it becomes leaving the united kingdom yeah and the partition and everything so just dominic just give us fill us in on the background of because a treaty is signed between the united kingdom and this kind of emergent Irish free state in 1921. And whether you accept this treaty or not, if you're Irish, becomes a key determinant. Okay, thanks, Tom.
劳合·乔治和丘吉尔看着这些枪，他们说，天哪，你知道，这就是一个小时前枪杀亨利·威尔逊爵士的枪，这两人他们都非常熟悉。这在某种程度上成了爱尔兰内战的导火索。爱尔兰内战，对吧？但它也作为一个句号存在于谈判进程中，这一进程导致了……爱尔兰离开自由邦——也就是后来的名称——离开联合王国，是的，还有划分等等。所以，多米尼克，给我们讲讲背景吧，因为1921年联合王国和这个新兴的爱尔兰自由邦之间签署了一项条约。作为一个爱尔兰人，你是否接受这个条约，成了一个决定性的关键。好的，谢谢你，汤姆。
So an Englishman trying to sum up the complexities of Irish politics in the early 20s in like 30 seconds. What could possibly go wrong? We've had so many Irish listeners say, why don't you do something on the Irish Civil War? And the reason for that is... It's your terror. It's your terror.
所以，一个英国人试图在30秒内总结20年代初爱尔兰政治的复杂性。怎么可能会出错呢？我们有那么多爱尔兰听众说，你们为什么不做一期关于爱尔兰内战的节目呢？原因就在于……这是你们的梦魇。这是你们的梦魇。
So I hope Irish listeners will forgive Dominic's summation that he's now about to give. So ever since the Easter Rising in 1916, and particularly... Terrible beauty is born. In the final years of the 1910s and the first years of the 1920s, violence has come to the streets and the countryside of Ireland as the IRA have been fighting for independence from Britain. And at the end of 1921, to cut a very long story short, the sort of Irish plenipotentiaries who have come to London have agreed a deal. They've been browbeaten
所以我希望爱尔兰听众能原谅多米尼克即将做出的总结。自从1916年的复活节起义以来，特别是……可怕的美丽诞生了。在1910年代末和1920年代初的几年里，暴力已经蔓延到爱尔兰的街道和乡村，因为爱尔兰共和军一直在为脱离英国而战。在1921年底，为了长话短说，来到伦敦的爱尔兰全权代表们已经达成了一项协议。他们受到胁迫
partly into agreeing a deal, the Anglo-Irish Treaty, in which basically what was then called Southern Ireland will get, well, all of Ireland actually, will get self-governing status within the British Empire as a dominion,
部分原因是同意了一项协议，即《英爱条约》，其中基本上当时被称为南爱尔兰的地区将获得——实际上是整个爱尔兰——在大英帝国内部获得自治地位，作为一个自治领，
rather like Canada, Australia. And so it's like lorging the crown. Yeah, it'll be the Irish free state. Now, the people who sit in the doyle will have to swear an oath of allegiance to the king. So the king will still, King George V will still be the king. They'll have to swear an oath of allegiance, which a lot of people don't like. And there's one other element that a lot of people don't like perhaps they don't which they know
很像加拿大、澳大利亚。所以这就像是向王室效忠。是的，这将是爱尔兰自由邦。现在，坐在爱尔兰议会（Dáil）里的人必须宣誓效忠国王。所以国王，乔治五世国王仍将是国王。他们必须宣誓效忠，很多人不喜欢这一点。还有一个很多人可能不喜欢、但他们也知道
is probably inevitable which is that northern ireland will be given a month to withdraw from the irish free state if they want and stay in the united kingdom and everybody knows that northern ireland because of its protestant population yeah will will will make so. So Catholics are about 20%. Is that right at that point? Something like that. Well, I think possibly slightly more, but yeah, you're right. There are obviously some areas of Northern Ireland that are very strongly Catholic.
可能是不可避免的因素，那就是北爱尔兰如果愿意的话，将被给予一个月的时间退出爱尔兰自由邦，并留在联合王国。大家都知道北爱尔兰由于其新教徒人口，是的，将会——将会——将会做出这样的选择。所以天主教徒大约占20%？那个时候是这样吗？差不多吧。嗯，我觉得可能稍微多一点，不过是的，你说的对。北爱尔兰显然有一些地区天主教徒非常多。
So a lot of people expect that there'll be some swapping after partition, which actually never really... Which doesn't happen. In the Levant. But yes, so basically the treaty is agreed now the the key thing um uh which will surprise people who don't know anything about irish politics is that the main figure on the irish side amon de valera has not come to london um with his men to sign the treaty. And there are all kinds of theories about and speculations about why he doesn't do it.
所以很多人预计划分边界后会有一些领土交换，但实际上并没有真正……并没有发生。在黎凡特。但是，是的，所以基本上条约现在达成了，关键的事情——这将令任何对爱尔兰政治一无所知的人感到惊讶——爱尔兰方面的主要人物埃蒙·德瓦莱拉并没有带着他的人来伦敦签署条约。关于他为什么不来，有各种各样的理论和猜测。
Some people say that basically he doesn't do this for cynical reasons because he doesn't want to be associated. Doesn't want to dabble his fingers in the blood of compromise. He knows that they'll have to compromise and he doesn't want to be party to it. So basically what happens is when they bring the treaty back,
有人说他基本上出于冷嘲热讽的原因不这么做，因为他不想被牵连。不想把手指沾上妥协的鲜血。他知道他们必须妥协，而他不想成为其中的一方。所以基本上发生的情况是，当他们把条约带回来时，
the key guy, by the way, in negotiating the treaty is a man called Michael Collins. And when they bring the treaty back the key guy by the way in in negotiating the treaty is a man called michael collins and has he been the hero of a film he's played by liam neeson yes he is tom can you do a michael collins i will find you and i will kill you is it that or as you would say i will kill you uh let's reverse i should never have mentioned this anyway if you want to hear tom's version of liam neeson you should listen to our podcast in the cia uh it's gone down as one of the most the landmark impersonations in modern cultural history but anyway michael collins was the head of intelligence uh for the ira he said everybody in the british side says this is a tremendously
顺便说一句，谈判条约的关键人物是一个名叫迈克尔·科林斯的人。当他们把条约带回来时，谈判条约的关键人物是一个名叫迈克尔·科林斯的人，他曾是一部电影的英雄吗？他由连姆·尼森饰演，是的，汤姆，你能来一段迈克尔·科林斯的模仿吗？我会找到你，我也会杀了你。是这样吗？或者按你的说法，我会杀了你。呃，让我们倒回，我本来就不该提这个的。总之，如果你想听汤姆版本的连姆·尼森，你应该去听我们在中情局的播客……这被载入了现代文化史上最具标志性的模仿之一。但不管怎样，迈克尔·科林斯曾是爱尔兰共和军的情报主管，英国方面所有人都说这是一个了不起的……
impressive young man i mean he does look a bit like Liam Neeson, actually. He does. Yes. He doesn't look like you. I don't think he looks like you at all. No. I don't think you could play my,
令人印象深刻的年轻人，我的意思是，他其实看起来确实有点像连姆·尼森。确实有点。是的。他看起来不像你。我觉得他一点儿也不像你。不。我觉得你演不了我的，
I mean, I can play Thomas Beckett and Paddington. I could play him on a BBC radio drama. It's obviously the power of my, my accent and voice. You could, you could you could are you pitching for work i am in the centenary production what could possibly go wrong so anyway collins comes back with the treaty de valera doesn't like it um so it passes the doyle the
我的意思是，我能演托马斯·贝克特和帕丁顿熊。我能在BBC广播剧中扮演他。这显然是我那，我那口音和嗓音的魅力。你可以，你可以，你可以——你是在毛遂自荐吗？我在《百年纪念》制作中——怎么可能会出错呢？所以不管怎样，柯林斯带着条约回来了，德瓦莱拉不喜欢它，嗯——所以它在道尔通过了，
irish parliament um but de valera it passes by seven votes but de valera doesn't like it at all and de valera actually campaigns against the treaty that his own allies have negotiated so he basically says the ira will wade through the blood of the soldiers of the of the soldiers of the irish government to get their freedom if necessary so basically the stage is set for the sinn fein and and the IRA to fall out among themselves. Because they're all Sinn Féin. They're all Sinn Féin. So actually Ireland has a general election in June,
爱尔兰议会，嗯——但是德瓦莱拉，它以七票之差通过了，但德瓦莱拉一点也不喜欢它，德瓦莱拉甚至公开反对他自己的盟友谈判达成的条约，所以他基本上说，如果有必要，爱尔兰共和军将踏着爱尔兰政府士兵的鲜血去争取他们的自由，所以基本上，这就为新芬党和爱尔兰共和军内部的决裂搭好了舞台。因为他们都是新芬党。他们都是新芬党。所以实际上爱尔兰在六月举行了一场大选，
four days before the murder of Sir Henry Wilson, where there are two Sinn Féin parties running against each other, one pro-treaty, one anti-treaty. And the pro-treaty win. But what's also complicating things is there's still quite a lot of violence on the ground. And in April, some anti-treaty IRA men have occupied the Four Courts complex in Dublin,
就在亨利·威尔逊爵士遇刺前四天，当时有两个新芬党派互相竞争，一个支持条约，一个反对条约。支持条约的一派获胜了。但让情况变得复杂的还有，地面上仍然有很多暴力活动。到了四月，一些反条约的爱尔兰共和军成员占领了都柏林的四法院建筑群，
which is this big sort of complex of courthouses. As a part of that, they think that by occupying these buildings, they will provoke British reprisals and that that will allow the war, that will mean the war starts again. To start up again, yeah. And that that will unite all the... Now, so they're there in the forecourts and the British have not yet reacted.
这是一个规模很大的法院建筑群。作为其中的一部分，他们认为通过占领这些建筑，会激起英国人的报复，而这将会引发战争，也就是说战争会重新开始。重新开始，是的。并且这会团结所有……现在，所以他们占领了四法院，而英国人还没有做出反应。
The British haven't reacted for once, unbelievably. But also, they still have possession of Dublin Castle, I think. Yes, there are still British troops. There's a military, they've got guns and artillery and all kinds of stuff exactly so the british are poised but unbelievably for once for once in the entire history of ireland the british stay their hand restraint exactly so normally what happens and even in the 70s is the british make absolutely catastrophic decisions and are far too heavy handed but for once they don't do anything. But that night after Sir Henry, you mentioned Sir Henry Wilson.
难以置信的是，英国人破天荒地没有做出反应。而且，我想他们还占领着都柏林城堡。是的，仍然有英国军队。有一支军队，他们有枪支、大炮和各种各样的东西——没错，所以英国人蓄势待发，但难以置信的是，破天荒地，在爱尔兰的整个历史上破天荒地，英国人克制了，保持了克制。没错，所以通常发生的情况，甚至在70年代也是如此，英国人会做出绝对灾难性的决定，手段过于严厉，但这一次他们什么也没做。但在那天晚上，在亨利爵士遇害之后，你提到了亨利爵士。
Sir Henry Wilson is killed. And the British say, OK, we've had enough. They blame this, some people think possibly wrongly, on the men who have taken over the Four Courts complex in Dublin. Is it not a possibility that Michael Collins was actually behind it?
亨利爵士遇害了。英国人说，够了，我们受够了。他们把这归咎于占领了都柏林四法院建筑群的人，有些人认为这可能是一种误判。迈克尔·柯林斯其实是幕后主使，难道这种可能性不存在吗？
Yes, it is. That he'd given the order but then forgotten about it? It is a possibility. It's incredibly unclear who gave the order to kill Sam. Or indeed if anyone did, maybe these two men just did it. Exactly right. The British side, Lloyd George and Churchill,
是的，确实存在。他下达了命令，但后来又忘得一干二净？这是一种可能。到底是谁下达了刺杀萨姆的命令，或者到底有没有人下达过，这极其不明确，也许这两个人就是自己干的。完全正确。英国方面，劳合·乔治和丘吉尔，
who were the kind of prime movers in the government at this point in their relations with Ireland, they basically say, OK, enough is enough. You know, get your house in order. If you won't kick these guys out of the forecourts, we will do it for you. And so on the 28th of June, so that's what, six days later, well, they actually, I've got that wrong, Tom.
他们是当时英国与爱尔兰关系中的主要推动者，他们基本上说，好了，够了。你知道的，把你们内部的事情处理好。如果你们不把这些家伙赶出四法院，我们就代劳了。所以在6月28日，也就是，六天后，好吧，其实，汤姆，我记错了。
They say to the British garrison, it's time for you to act. And actually the commander of the British garrison, he says, I think not sure about that. He says, I think we should wait and give Collins a chance to do it first. Again, unbelievably a British general. Which Collins then does. And you know, at WB Yeats,
他们对英国驻军说，是时候行动了。而实际上英国驻军的指挥官说，我觉得——对那个不太确定。他说，我觉得我们应该等等，给柯林斯一个先动手的机会。再次展现了英国将军难以置信的作风。柯林斯随后也这么做了。你知道，叶芝，
we've had a lot of poetry in this. Actually, Yeats, we had Yeats in the episode on the Rubicon. Did you see what Yeats, it's quoted quoted by Kevin Jackson in Constellation Genius, what Yates said on the morning of the 28th of June? I don't. You're going to tell me, though. All is, I think, going well.
我们在这集里讲了很多诗歌。实际上，叶芝，我们在讲卢比孔河的那一集里就提到过叶芝。你看到叶芝——凯文·杰克逊在《星座天才》中引用了叶芝在6月28日早晨说的话吗？我不知道。不过你打算告诉我。我想一切都进展顺利。
And the principle, I think Yates spoke like that, didn't he? All is, I think, going well. And the principal result of this turmoil would be love of order in the people and a stability in the government not otherwise obtainable. Oh, my God. Don't go to the eights for political prognostication. Yeah, so he's a great poet. But as a political pundit, he's maybe...
而且，我想叶芝说话就是那个调调，对吧？一切，我想，都进展顺利。这场动荡的主要结果将是人民对秩序的热爱，以及政府前所未有的稳定。哦，天哪。千万别找叶芝做政治预测。是的，所以他是个伟大的诗人。但作为一个政治评论家，他可能……
He said that on the very morning that the war started. He said that on the very morning of the start of the war on the 28th of June when Collins goes in hard against the anti-treaty men. Yeah, so Collins basically orders the recapture of the four courts, and that starts a week of very heavy fighting in Dublin. And then basically the Irish Civil War, the Irish government, so Collins,
他在战争爆发的那个早晨说了这话。他在6月28日战争爆发的那个早晨说了这话，当时柯林斯正全力以赴打击反条约派。是的，所以柯林斯基本上命令重新夺回四法院，这开启了都柏林持续一周的激烈战斗。然后基本上爱尔兰内战爆发了，爱尔兰政府，也就是柯林斯，
the pro-treaty forces quite quickly capture all the major towns, so Cork and Waterford and so on. But the guerrilla fighting goes on and Collins himself is ambushed on the 22nd of August and is killed outside Cork in County Cork. Do you know who else gets shot at in the Irish Civil War? You're going to tell me.
支持条约的军队非常迅速地攻占了所有主要城镇，比如科克、沃特福德等等。但游击战仍在继续，柯林斯本人于8月22日在科克郡科克郊外遭到伏击并被杀害。你知道在爱尔兰内战中还有谁差点被枪击吗？你打算告诉我了。
Who we've mentioned in this podcast yesterday. We mentioned yesterday. Who did we mention yesterday? Lenin. Irish. No, it's an Irish person. Is it James Joyce? It's not James Joyce, but you're in the right ballpark.
我们在昨天这期播客中提到过的人。我们昨天提到过。我们昨天提到了谁？列宁。爱尔兰人。不，是个爱尔兰人。是詹姆斯·乔伊斯吗？不是詹姆斯·乔伊斯，但你猜的大方向是对的。
It's Nora Barnacle. So Joyce's wife by this point, originally from Galway, and she goes with her two children back to Galway. And obviously she's married to James Joyce, so they're not interested in international politics at all. They haven't noticed there's a war. So she goes to her house in Galway and discovers that it's being used for target practice. So she thinks, oh, I'm not sure about this.
是诺拉·巴纳克尔。所以此时已经是乔伊斯的妻子了，原籍戈尔韦，她带着两个孩子回到了戈尔韦。显然她嫁给了詹姆斯·乔伊斯，所以他们对国际政治一点也不感兴趣。他们根本没注意到打仗了。于是她去了她在戈尔韦的房子，发现那里正在被当成靶场使用。所以她想，噢，这我可说不准。
So she gets on the train and then people start shooting at the train. Oh, my word. Joyce was wise to stay in Zurich. Yeah, he was. And so she gets to Dublin and goes back to Paris. I think she never gets back to Ireland, I think. Well, you wouldn't, would you, if you were shut out? No, I think so.
于是她上了火车，然后人们开始向火车开枪。哦，天哪。乔伊斯留在苏黎世是明智的。是的，确实如此。然后她到了都柏林，又回到了巴黎。我想她再也没有回过爱尔兰吧。嗯，换作是你被拒之门外，你也不会回去，对吧？对，我想是的。
So, yeah. Yeah, so she has an experience of it. So it's quite a sort of grim story, all things considered. The death toll, I have to say, by comparison with some of the other death tolls we've been talking about in these 1922 podcasts, it's not massive. I mean, probably irish people die in the in the civil war than in the war of independence oddly so probably about 2 000 people die and there are also some pretty horrific killings in belfast so there are kind of what people call perhaps with with with pardonable exaggeration they're kind of called pogroms of catholic
所以，是的。是的，所以她亲身经历了这一切。总而言之，这是一个相当阴暗的故事。我必须说，与我们在这些1922年播客中讨论过的一些其他死亡人数相比，这次的死亡人数并不算庞大。我的意思是，奇怪的是，在内战中死去的爱尔兰人可能比在独立战争中还要少，大概有2000人左右死亡，而且在贝尔法斯特也发生了一些相当骇人听闻的谋杀案，所以有一种人们称之为——也许可以算作是情有可原的夸大——被称为针对天主教的 pogrom（大屠杀）
civilians so there's a uh killing of them at mar a man family in this what's called the arnon street killings in the spring of 1922 um but in general so about two two thousand people probably die in the irish war of independence and they're always burning down country houses aren't exactly a lot of country houses are kind of sacked and despoiled and so on but that actually pales by comparison with what's going on at the same time which kind of monopolizes a lot of british interest in the middle east so right so although we were talking about britain being sort of top nation big empire there's a constant sense of firefighting and and kind of um struggling to cope with all these crises sort of and if we're talking about 1922 as a year where the modern world, as its foundations, I think's the Persian Empire, Macedonians, Romans, Arabs, Ottomans,
平民，所以呃，在1922年春天的阿尔农街谋杀案中，有一个马尔家族遭到了杀害；但总的来说，大约有两千人死于爱尔兰独立战争，而且乡村宅邸总是被烧毁，不是吗？确实有很多乡村宅邸遭到洗劫和破坏等等，但这与当时在中东发生的事情相比就相形见绌了，那件事垄断了英国对中东的大部分兴趣，对吧——所以尽管我们一直在谈论英国作为顶级大国、庞大帝国的地位，但总有一种疲于灭火、苦苦挣扎着应对所有这些危机的感觉，而且如果我们把1922年视为现代世界奠定其基础的一年——我想这是波斯帝国、马其顿人、罗马人、阿拉伯人、奥斯曼人，
and the collapse of the Ottoman Empire. It's the end of an era and the beginning of the era that we now live in. Absolutely. I mean, the Ottoman Empire, when did the Ottomans start? 13th century? Yeah. The empire is a successor to Byzantium. You're looking from 1453 onwards.
以及奥斯曼帝国的崩溃。这是一个时代的结束，也是我们今天所处时代的开始。绝对是的。我的意思是，奥斯曼帝国，奥斯曼人是什么时候开始的？13世纪？是的。这个帝国是拜占庭帝国的继承者。你要从1453年及以后看起。
And the Ottoman Empire has been the bulwark of order, I suppose, in the Near East for as, you know, what are we talking, 700 years? I mean, it's often very brutal. I mean, I think the Yazidis for instance, would, would not say that Ottoman imperialism was, was anything tremendous,
奥斯曼帝国一直是近东秩序的堡垒，我想，维持了多久，你知道的，我们在说什么，700年？我的意思是，它通常非常残酷。我的意思是，我认为例如雅兹迪人，会——不会认为奥斯曼帝国主义是什么了不起的东西，
but it, like all the previous, you know, all the previous great empires, multi multiculturalism, multi ethnic cities are just the way things are. So whether it's Alexandria, whether it's Smyrna or Izmir, as the Turks call it,
但它，就像所有以前的，你知道的，所有以前伟大的帝国一样，多元文化主义、多民族城市就是现实本来的样子。所以无论是亚历山大港，无论是士麦那，还是土耳其人所称的伊兹密尔，
whether it's Constantinople or Istanbul, as it will become. These are great polyglot cities full of merchants from across the Levant, so Greeks and Turks and Jews and Syrians and Egyptians, and they're all mixed up. And what happens in 1922 is that you start to get the population swaps that you don't get in Ireland in this period, where basically the idea of ethnically-based nation-states or faith-based nation based nation states starts to emerge from out of the kind of very, very ancient chrysalis of this idea of the universal empire.
无论是君士坦丁堡还是后来的伊斯坦布尔。这些都是伟大的多语种城市，充满了来自整个黎凡特的商人，所以有希腊人、土耳其人、犹太人、叙利亚人和埃及人，他们都混居在一起。而1922年发生的事情是，你开始看到人口大置换，而这在这一时期的爱尔兰是没有的，基本上，基于民族的民族国家或基于信仰的民族国家这一概念，开始从这种普遍帝国理念极其古老的茧中破茧而出。
And it's a horribly bloody process. It's extraordinary. I mean, it's extraordinary in some ways that the Ottoman Empire is still still is still a legal entity uh as late as 22 because they've lost the the first world war the british have taken over the british and french have taken over in the levant haven't they yeah so the british have been in palestine but i think um you have a fact don't you about the uh the league of nations only approves the british mandate that's right yes yeah in 1922 and i think that again that's really in so the obviously the um the balfour declaration means that the british are
这是一个极其血腥的过程。这太不可思议了。我的意思是，在某些方面，奥斯曼帝国直到1922年居然仍然是一个法律实体，这简直不可思议，因为他们已经输掉了第一次世界大战，英国人已经接管了，英国人和法国人在黎凡特接管了，对吧？是的，所以英国人一直在巴勒斯坦，但我想，呃，你掌握了一个事实，对吧？关于呃国际联盟只批准了英国托管地？没错，是的，是的，在1922年，我认为这再次非常——所以显然呃，贝尔福宣言意味着英国人
um well they've got the balfour declaration and they've got the promise that they've made to um various uh arab princes yeah and they attempt to balance this by setting up the Hashemite kingdom, Transjordan, or become the Kingdom of Jordan, and allowing Jewish immigration into Palestine. The Jewish population of Palestine grows by 10% year on, year on, year on throughout the 20s but the fact that that this gets rubber stamped by the league of nations i think is actually significant because britain britain although it's captured palestine um as a result of it you know alanby moving in in in the in 1917 in the in the war there is a sense that that that that britain now and all the great powers are answerable to a kind of international standard of behavior. And that is kind of new. And it's something in a way stake in is something that is first
嗯，他们有了贝尔福宣言，他们有了对各种呃阿拉伯亲王做出的承诺，是的，他们试图通过建立哈希姆王国、外约旦（后来成为约旦王国）并允许犹太人移民到巴勒斯坦来平衡这一点。巴勒斯坦的犹太人口在整个20年代每年都在以10%的速度增长，但这一决定得到国际联盟的正式批准，我认为这确实意义重大，因为英国——英国尽管占领了巴勒斯坦——作为（你知道的）艾伦比在1917年战争中进入的结果，有一种感觉，即英国现在和所有大国都要对一种国际行为标准负责。这可以说是全新的。某种程度上，这在某种程度上首次
signaled in 1922 by the league of nations giving its imprimatur to the british mandate yeah i suppose what you can say is you um the great european empires are deferring to a sense of of kind of international morality aren't they but they're also they're also trying to provide a degree of international supervision to a process of population transfer that is on an absolutely massive scale but what happens in palestine is not what happens in turkey so that's the contrast isn't it that when palestine you have this ethnic mix which is never ironed out as it were forcibly so you still have to this day well well but you are getting a kind of population swap in that you're getting jews who are coming in yeah and who are starting to buy land i mean it's it's a kind of it's it's it's a very very slow
在1922年由国联对英国托管地给予正式认可时得到了暗示。是的，我想你可以说，你——欧洲各大国正在顺应一种国际道德感，对吧，但他们也在试图为一场绝对大规模的人口转移进程提供一定程度的国际监督。但巴勒斯坦发生的事情与土耳其发生的事情不同，这就是对比，对吧？在巴勒斯坦，你拥有这种从未被强行彻底抹平的民族融合，所以直到今天你仍然拥有——不过你确实正在经历一种人口置换，因为有犹太人不断涌入，是的，并且开始购买土地。我的意思是，这是一种非常非常慢动作的人口置换，显然会因第二次世界大战的事件而加速，但你没有的是——但是你确实——但是你被第二次世界大战的事件加速了，但你没有的是——但是你确实——但你并没有那种在1922年希腊人和土耳其人之间发生的巨大而即时的人口大置换，我的意思是，那个故事如果你不带着那种双方巨大的失落感和悲剧感去阅读，是很难读下去的，绝对是的，是的，好吧。
motion population swap that will obviously be expedited by the events of the second world war but what you don't have is but what you but you did yes but but you expedited by the events of the second world war but what you don't have is but what you but you did yes but but you don't have the kind of massive instantaneous population swaps that you do get in 1922 between greeks and turks i mean that that is a story that it's very hard to read without feeling this tremendous sense of kind of loss and tragedy on both sides absolutely nothing yeah well. Well, again, you know, we're talking about how old the roots of this order are in the Levant, and there have been Greeks, you know,
嗯，再说一次，你知道的，我们在谈论这种秩序在黎凡特的根基有多深，自特洛伊战争以来，爱琴海的土耳其海岸就一直有希腊人存在，
on the Turkish coast of the Aegean since the time of the Trojan War. Yeah. I mean, just think when we did our Alexander the Great podcast, Alexander marching through all these cities, Sardis, Miletus, Halicarnassus. Yeah. And that world is about...
你知道的。我的意思是，想想当我们做亚历山大大帝的那期播客时，亚历山大行军穿过所有这些城市：萨尔迪斯、米利都、哈利卡那索斯。是的。而那个世界大约……
And Constantinople was a Greek-speaking empire. Yeah. And all of that is lost. And in a way, the Greeks bring it on themselves. I mean, it's a kind of land grab. They've been on the Allied side. The Turks have lost. And the Greeks say, grab they're trying you know after they've been on the allied side the turks have lost and the greeks say you know we what we want as our reward is to revive the byzantine empire
君士坦丁堡曾是一个讲希腊语的帝国。是的。而这一切都失去了。某种程度上，希腊人是自取灭亡。我的意思是，这是一种土地掠夺。他们曾站在盟军一边。土耳其人战败了，希腊人说，掠夺——他们试图（你知道的）在他们站在盟军一边、土耳其人战败之后，希腊人说（你知道的），我们作为回报想要的是复兴拜占庭帝国，
basically you know i suppose you can see it from of course everything is up for grabs in the collapse of the ottoman empire but no one knows what's going to happen um the greeks have invaded yeah they have overreached they've marched so 1922 they get defeated the battle of saccaria which is the furthest that they get into anatolia and they're defeated by uh muster kemmel who was the hero for the turks of glippoli yeah and he then drives the greeks back and the great great tragedy horror atrocity is in September, the burning of Smyrna, Izmir, one of the great, great melting pots of the Mediterranean, which gets absolutely wiped out.
基本上（你知道的），我想你可以从——当然在奥斯曼帝国的崩溃中一切都在争夺之中，没有人知道会发生什么，嗯，希腊人入侵了，是的，他们做得过头了。他们一路进军——所以在1922年，他们在萨卡里亚战役中战败了，那是他们深入安纳托利亚的最远距离，他们被穆斯塔法·凯末尔击败了，后者是土耳其人在加里波利的英雄，是的，他随后将希腊人击退，而那场巨大、巨大、可怕的暴行发生在9月，士麦那（伊兹密尔）的大火，地中海最伟大的大熔炉之一，被彻底毁灭了。
Yeah, about 100,000. I mean, we're talking about death tolls. 100,000 people probably died in the sack of Smyrna. So basically what happens is, as you say, the Greeks have overextended themselves. The Turks pushed them all the way back to Smyrna. And then the Greeks and the entire Greek and Armenian population of Smyrna and all international citizens are on the quayside, basically.
是的，大约10万人。我的意思是，我们在谈论死亡人数。在士麦那的洗劫中，可能有10万人丧生。所以基本上发生的事情是，正如你所说，希腊人把战线拉得太长了。土耳其人将他们一路逼回士麦那。然后士麦那的整个希腊和亚美尼亚人口以及所有国际公民都挤在码头上，基本上是这样。
And the city is burning. And a lot of them don't have time to get away. And Mustafa Kemal does give orders to his army to restrain themselves, don't kill any civilians and stuff. But as both armies had throughout this war, I mean, it's an incredibly horrible story. Both the Greeks and the Turks had committed endless atrocities against civilians in the course of the war,
而城市正在燃烧。他们中的很多人根本来不及逃走。穆斯塔法·凯末尔确实下达命令让他的军队保持克制，不要杀害平民等等。但正如两支军队在这场战争中所做的那样——我的意思是，这是一个极其可怕的故事——希腊人和土耳其人在战争期间都对平民犯下了无数暴行，
as is inevitable, I suppose, when course of the war as is inevitable i suppose when you have a war that is driven by a kind of sense of national and ethnic sort of self-affirmation and i'm sure that that's you know that's what elliot is is kind of alluding to in his image of of cities unreal cities cracking and and reforming and well there's a there's a there's somebody from smyrna yeah mr eugenides smyrna merchant's somebody from Smyrna in the wasteland. Yeah, Mr. Eugenides, the Smyrna merchant. So there are echoes of it throughout the wasteland. Yeah, but I think that that establishes the geopolitical contours of the Near East,
这是不可避免的，我想，当——当进行一场由某种国家和民族自我宣示的驱动的战争时，这是不可避免的，而且我确信这正是——你知道的，这也是艾略特在他的城市意象中暗指的：不真实的城市在裂开、重组，而且——好吧，有一个——士麦那来的人，是的，尤金尼德斯先生，士麦那商人——荒原里有一个士麦那来的人。是的，尤金尼德斯先生，士麦那商人。所以在整部《荒原》中都有它的回响。是的，但我认为这确立了近东、
of Greece, of Egypt, of Israel, of Palestine, that we still have. But what it also does, Tom, in a way that's in a really surprising link, it helps to create modern British politics. Okay, so tell me about that. So this is a really fascinating story. So Mustafa Kemal has taken Smyrna. He has basically taken Ionia, the region that the Greeks wanted in Asia Minor.
希腊、埃及、以色列、巴勒斯坦的地缘政治轮廓，这些轮廓至今犹存。但汤姆，它还做了一件事，以一种令人非常意外的联系，它帮助塑造了现代英国政治。好吧，那跟我讲讲这个。这是一个非常迷人的故事。所以穆斯塔法·凯末尔占领了士麦那。他基本上占领了伊奥尼亚，也就是希腊人梦寐以求的小亚细亚地区。
There's one bit left and that is constantinople and the area around constantinople and eastern thrace and that is being occupied by the allies by the british and the french and at the end of september must have a camel is closing in on this area um so this is in some ways the last act of the First World War. He's closing in on the British there. And Lloyd George and Churchill, who I talked about before with Ireland. So Lloyd George is the prime minister. He's the former. Well, he's still a liberal, but he's basically sold out.
还剩下一小块地方，那就是君士坦丁堡以及君士坦丁堡周围的地区和东色雷斯，这一地区正被盟军——英国人和法国人占领。在9月底，穆斯塔法·凯末尔正在逼近这个地区，嗯——所以在某种程度上，这是第一次世界大战的最后一幕。他在那里逼近英国人。而劳合·乔治和丘吉尔——我之前在讲爱尔兰时提到过他们。所以劳合·乔治是首相。他是前任——好吧，他仍然是个自由党人，但他基本上背叛了。
He's not a friend of this podcast. I think it's fair to say. You're very hostile to him. He's just basically, in my mind, an absolutely terrible man. Hemingway hostile to him. He's just basically an absolute, in my mind, an absolutely terrible man. Hemingway adored him. Yeah, but Hemingway adored kind of great men, didn't he? Yeah.
他不是这个朋友播客的粉丝。我觉得这么说很公平。你对他充满敌意。在我的脑海里，他基本上是一个彻头彻尾的糟糕透顶的人。海明威对他充满敌意。在我的脑海里，他基本上是一个彻头彻尾的糟糕透顶的人。海明威很崇拜他。是的，但海明威崇拜那种伟人，不是吗？是的。
As Churchill did. Lloyd George has abandoned a lot of his old kind of Welsh radicalism. He's become a very establishment figure. He's been prime minister too long. He's incredibly corrupt. And they sit there in Downing Street and they say if the turks attack we must go to war and so two interesting things happen first of all they say we and the empire will go to war against the turks so we'll now you know we'll throw britain churchill who has completely not learned his lesson from gallipoli yeah it's like crack yeah let's have another crack. Yeah, let's have another go. Worked brilliantly last time.
正如丘吉尔所做的那样。劳合·乔治已经抛弃了他过去的很多威尔士激进主义。他已经变成了一个非常体制化的人物。他当首相的时间太长了。他腐败得令人难以置信。他们坐在唐宁街说，如果土耳其人进攻，我们就必须开战。于是发生了两件有趣的事：首先，他们说我们和帝国将对土耳其宣战，所以我们现在（你知道的）要把英国——丘吉尔完全没有吸取加里波利的教训，是的，就像一剂猛药，是的，再来一次。是的，再干一场。上次效果好极了。
And one interesting thing that happens is that Canada, Mackenzie King, the Canadian Prime Minister, says, you know, they say, just to check you're all on board with this. And he says, no, I'm absolutely not on board at all. Britain must stop assuming that Canada will just pitch up and throw our men into battle. So that's, you know, talking about straws in the wind for the empire, that's a really, really telling and important moment that Canada is not going to be just an appendage
发生的一件有趣的事情是，加拿大，麦肯齐·金，加拿大总理说，你知道的，他们说，只是为了确认你们都赞成这件事。而他说，不，我绝对一点也不赞成。英国必须停止想当然地认为加拿大只要一招手就会把我们的子弟送上战场。所以，你知道的，说到帝国风向的微小信号，这是一个非常非常说明问题且重要的时刻，加拿大将不再仅仅是英国的附属品，
to Britain anymore. A blank check. But the second thing is, Lloyd George is leading a coalition government and many of the Tories are absolutely sick of Lloyd George. They think he's corrupt. They think he's dangerous. They think he would be a dictator.
一张空白支票。但第二件事是，劳合·乔治领导着一个联合政府，许多保守党人对劳合·乔治厌恶至极。他们认为他腐败。他们认为他危险。他们认为他会成为一个独裁者。
And they don't want to have a war with Turkey. Lloyd George decides he wants an election. And he wants the election. And is the election fought around this issue? No, it's not going to be fought around this issue because it's become increasingly clear that nobody really wants this war. But he decides to go for an election anyway um the tourists are due to have a meeting
而且他们不想与土耳其开战。劳合·乔治决定他想要举行大选。他想要这场大选。这场大选是围绕这个议题展开的吗？不，不会围绕这个议题展开，因为越来越明显的是，没有人真正想要这场战争。但他还是决定举行大选，嗯——保守党定于举行一次会议，
on where is it on the 19th of october at the carlton club you know this you're a great man for clubs tom st james's club just down from your club brooks's um they're going to have the meeting of all the tory the tory sort of backbenchers and so on to decide will they fight the election 1922 in 1922 yeah the 19 i see where this is going the 1922 committee is today the sort of the the caucus of tory backbenchers and it takes its name ultimately from this moment so they meet and their leader, Austin Chamberlain, who is the son of the great Joseph Chamberlain and who basically is a pale shadow of his father,
地点在哪里？在10月19日的卡尔顿俱乐部——你知道这个，你是个热衷俱乐部的行家，汤姆，圣詹姆斯俱乐部，就在你的俱乐部布鲁克斯俱乐部旁边——他们将举行所有保守党——保守党后座议员等等的会议，以决定他们是否要在1922年参加大选——在1922年？是的，19——我明白这是怎么回事了。1922委员会今天就是保守党后座议员的核心集团，它的名字最终就源于这个时刻。所以他们开会了，他们的领袖奥斯丁·张伯伦，他是伟大的约瑟夫·张伯伦的儿子，基本上只是他父亲的一个苍白影子，
who models himself on his father and orchid in his buttonhole. He says, well, we should absolutely back Lloyd George. He's a tremendous fellow and all the rest of it. And now finally making his podcast debut, one of the great men of history, the Midlands' own Stanley Baldwin. Yay! He stands up and says,
他以父亲为榜样，胸前别着兰花。他说，嗯，我们绝对应该支持劳合·乔治。他是个了不起的家伙，诸如此类。现在，终于迎来了他在本播客的首次亮相，历史上的伟人之一，米德尔斯本本土的斯坦利·鲍德温！耶！他站起来说，
no, we shouldn't fight it up with Lloyd George as the leader. Lloyd George is a dynamic force, and a dynamic force is a terrible thing. That's very Balfour. And the Tories vote. Sorry, did I say Balfour? I apologise. What did you say? I said Balfour? I apologise. What did you say? I said Balfour.
不，我们不应该以劳合·乔治为领袖去参战。劳合·乔治是一股充满活力的力量，而一股充满活力的力量是一件可怕的事情。这非常“贝尔福”。保守党人投票——抱歉，我刚才说贝尔福了吗？我道歉。你刚才说什么？我说了贝尔福？我道歉。你刚才说什么？我说了贝尔福。
Balfour. How could you do that to Stanley Baldwin? Sorry. He makes his appearance in the podcast and you mistake him for other Balfour. And I ruin it. I'm so sorry. I'm so sorry. So anyway, Baldwin helps to carry the day.
贝尔福。你怎么能对斯坦利·鲍德温做出这种事？抱歉。他第一次在播客中亮相，而你却把他错认成了另一个贝尔福。我把事情搞砸了。非常抱歉。非常抱歉。无论如何，鲍德温帮助扭转了局面。
The Tories agree to leave the coalition. Austin Chamberlain is out as the Tory leader. And the unknown Prime Minister, as he's later called, Bonner Law, born in Canada, Scottish extraction, self-made man, he comes in as Tory leader and there's going to be a general election. And the 1922 general election is one of the absolute landmark British general elections. So it happens in November, the day after the first radio broadcast.
保守党同意退出联合政府。奥斯丁·张伯伦不再担任保守党领袖。而后来被称为“未知首相”的博纳·劳，出生于加拿大，苏格兰血统，白手起家，他出任保守党领袖，即将举行大选。1922年大选是英国大选中绝对具有里程碑意义的一次。所以它发生在11月，也就是第一次无线电广播的第二天。
And I think to general surprise, the Tories win a massive victory. They win 344 seats. The Liberals, who had been the party of government taking Britain into the Great War, they're nowhere because they're divided between Asquith and Lloyd George. So Asquith gets 62 seats. Lloyd George gets 53. The Liberals are split, doomed, destroyed by the electoral system. And is another party coming up on the left flank? It is.
我想出乎大多数人的意料，保守党取得了压倒性胜利。他们赢得了344个议席。自由党——曾作为执政党带领英国进入大战的政党——彻底销声匿迹，因为他们在阿斯奎斯和劳合·乔治之间分裂了。所以阿斯奎斯获得了62个议席。劳合·乔治获得了53个。自由党分裂了，注定完蛋，被选举制度摧毁了。左翼有另一个政党正在崛起吗？是的。
The Labour Party, which has never before been one of the top two parties, comes second under its leader, J.R. Clines. Now, J.R. Clines is utterly forgotten. I've never heard of him. I would bet that of the listeners to this podcast, of the tens of thousands, hundreds of thousands of listeners to this podcast,
以前从未跻身前两大政党之列的工党，在领袖J·R·克莱ines的带领下取得了第二名。现在，J·R·克莱ines已经被彻底遗忘。我从未听说过他。我敢打赌，在这个播客的听众中——成千上万、数十万听众中，
millions, none but a handful will have heard of J.R. Klein's. So he's from Lancashire. He's an Irish background. He went to work in cotton mills at the age of 11, learned the Bible and Shakespeare and Milton by heart. Great. He is a man. That's the kind of Labour leader we want.
数百万听众中，除了极少数人外，没有人听说过J·R·克莱ines。所以他来自兰开夏郡。他有着爱尔兰血统。他11岁就去棉纺厂工作，将《圣经》、莎士比亚和弥尔顿的作品烂熟于心。太棒了。他是一个——这才是我们想要的工党领袖。
He is the kind of Labour leader you like. And he leads them to 142 seats. And from this point onwards, I mean, there are going to be two more elections in the next two years, but ultimately from this point onwards, British politics will become a fight between a middle class and Tory party
他正是你喜欢的这种工党领袖。他带领他们赢得了142个议席。从这一刻起——我的意思是，在接下来的两年里还会有另外两次大选——但最终从这一刻起，英国政治将成为一个中产阶级的保守党（赢得大约四分之一的工人阶级选票）与一个赢得其余工人阶级选票的工党之间的斗争，还有那些过去投自由党票的传统高尚的波希米亚人。所以这就是自由主义英格兰的奇异死亡。这就是自由主义英格兰的死亡。但是，汤姆，关于这一时期的政治，伟大的评论家——你知道这一时期的伟大政治评论家是谁吗，汤姆，你知道这一时期的英国政治伟大评论家是谁吗？是吗？是的，我知道，我不会剧透。所以你告诉我，多米尼克。
that wins maybe one in four working class votes and a labor party that wins the other working class votes and the kind of old high-minded kind of bohemian types who'd voted liberal in the past so this is the strange death of liberal england this is the death of liberal england but the great commentator on politics in this period tom you know who the great commentator on politics in this period, Tom, you know who the great commentator on British politics in this period is? Is it? Yes, I do know, and I'm not going to spoil it. So you tell me, Dominic.
好的。他们这样说：有四种人在试图成为统治者。他们都想把事情变好，但他们想用不同的方式让事情变好。有保守党人，他们想通过让事情保持现状来让事情变好。还有自由党人，他们想用不同的方式让事情变好。有保守党人，他们想通过让事情保持现状来让事情变好。还有自由党人，
Yeah. They put it this way. There are four sorts of people trying to get to be rulers. They all want to make things better, but they want to make them better in different ways. There's conservatives, and they want to make things better by keeping them just like what they are now. And there's liberals, and they want to make them better in different ways. There's conservatives, and they want to make things better by keeping them just like what they are now. And there's liberals,
他们想通过稍微改变一下事情来让事情变好，不过要改得让人注意不到。还有社会主义者，他们想通过把每个人的钱都拿走来让事情变好。还有共产主义者，他们想通过
and they want to make things better by altering them just a bit, but not so that anyone would notice. And there's socialists, and they want to make things better by taking everyone's money off them. And there's communists, and they want to make things better
杀死除了他们自己以外的所有人来让事情变好。你知道那是谁吗？小威廉。没错。好吧，那是小威廉的朋友亨利，他是这伙“法外之徒”帮派里的智囊。而且小威廉——这个播客的很多英国听众都会知道，他是终极淘气学童，由作家里奇蒙·克朗普顿在1922年创造，她是一位非常保守的小说家，她为女性杂志写这些故事，它们变得极其
by killing everyone but themselves. And you know who that is? Just William. It is. Well, it's William Brown's friend, Henry, who is the brain box of the gang the outlaws and and just william a lot of british listeners to this podcast will know he is the ultimate naughty schoolboy and he's created in 1922 by the writer richmond crompton very conservative novelist and she writes these stories for um women's magazines and they become tremendously
受欢迎，最终售出了数百万册。马丁·贾维斯的一生都在为这些故事录制精彩的有声书。威廉绝对是一个了不起的——这些故事是一个了不起的创造，这些故事是洞察20世纪20年代和30年代英格兰中部日常焦虑的最辉煌的视角窗口。它们充满了各种各样的爱管闲事的人、国际联盟热心者和禁酒主义者，他们总是搬到隔壁，试图把威廉拉进他们的计划中，而威廉总是破坏他们的计划并将其毁掉，最后所有男孩都会大打出手——是的，是的，它们很棒，
popular and sell end up selling millions and millions of copies martin jarvis um work for the rest of the rest of his life he does the brilliant audio books of them and william is an absolutely tremendous and and the stories he's a tremendous creation the stories are the most brilliant view viewpoint sort of window into the everyday anxieties of kind of middle england in the 1920s and 1930s they're full of all these sort of do gooders and league of nations enthusiasts and prohibitionists who are always moving into the house next door and trying to get william involved in their schemes and william always undermines their schemes and destroys them and it ends up with all the boys having a massive fight yeah it's yeah they're great
它们很棒。好吧，我认为这是一个绝佳的结束语，为我们的1922年之旅画上句号。多米尼克，你彻底说服了我，现代世界就是从那里开始的。还有一个——只有一个最后的问题。是的，我知道会是什么问题。我完全知道会是什么问题。所以这是一个来自节目之友和科技巨头的问题。你想把它读出来吗？来自马克·安德森，我想他是共同发明人。我想他会自称是共同发明人。我们叫他网络浏览器网景公司的发明者。他问，现代世界实际上持续了多久？
they're great well I think that's a wonderful note on which to end our tour of 1922 and Dominic you have completely convinced me that the modern world began there is just one there is just one last question yes I know what it's going to be I know know exactly what it's going to be. So it's from a friend of the show and a titan of tech. Would you like to read it out? It's from Mark Andreessen, who I think is the co-inventor. I think he would say co-inventor. We'll call him the inventor of the web browser, Netscape. And he says, how long did the modern world actually last?
我提名大约是1965年，但我很好奇你们是怎么想的。我觉得1965年是个相当不错的选择。我的意思是，这取决于你如何定义现代性，对吧？我的意思是，你会把它终结在……好吧，马克·安德森会这么认为——我的意思是，你知道的，他懂技术。是的。而我没有资格对此做出评判。
I nominate approximately 1965, but I'm curious what you guys think. 1965 is quite a good call, I think. I mean, it depends how you're defining modernity, doesn't it? I mean, would you end in... Well, Marc Andreessen would, I mean, you know, I mean, he knows his tech. Yeah. And I'm not qualified to judge on that.
但我会认为，实际上，比如广播和互联网之间的连续性是——我的意思是，它是那种可以识别的……所以你认为存在一种连续性？我确实认为存在一种连续性。你不认为微处理器之类的东西的到来是一个……我认为它只是加速了已经存在的趋势。我认为好莱坞是（你知道的）BBC，许多文化趋势都是文化和技术趋势。我认为现代性确实延续了下来。
But I would have thought that actually the continuity between, say, radio and the internet is, I mean, it's kind of recognisably... So you think there's a continuity? I do think there's a continuity. You don't think the arrival of the kind of microprocessor or something is a... I think it's sped up the trends that were already there. And I think Hollywood is, you know, BBC, that a lot of the cultural trends are cultural and technological trends. I think modernity does carry through.
我认为现代主义已经死了。我同意这一点。因为它被后现代主义取代了，不是吗？而且就在1965年。所以那种认为存在一条可以追溯的伟大传统的观念已经消失了。我们现在也许生活在一个后现代的世界里。所以关于这一点，汤姆，我可能同意你的看法。
I think the idea of modernism is dead. I agree with that. Because it gets replaced by postmodernism, doesn't it? And it is in 1965. So the idea that there is a kind of great tradition that you can trace through is gone. And we live in a maybe now a post-modern world. So I would probably agree with you about that, Tom.
我认为有些——我的意思是，假设你是从技术和流行文化的角度来考虑的。我认为你从20世纪20年代到大约20世纪80年代、90年代绝对拥有的是，你拥有某种文化垄断和技术垄断。例如在英国，BBC基本上创造了——而且我会说他们第一次创造了一个全国性的大众文化。
I think that some, I mean, let's say you're thinking about in terms of tech and in terms of kind of popular culture. I think what you definitely have from the 1920s through to probably the roundabout the 1980s, 1990s, is you have a kind of monopoly of culture and a monopoly of technology. So for example, in Britain, the BBC basically create, and I would say create a national mass culture for the first time.
一种——我承认这是现代的——全国性的大众文化，身处完全不同国家地区的人们在观看和收听相同的东西，分享相同的文化参考，拥有统一的全国性文化词汇等等。对于好莱坞这样的大公司，你也有同样的东西，所以你可以（你知道的）如果你在1977年看过《星球大战》，其他人也都看过；如果你看过《乱世佳人》，是的，其他人也都看过。这种情况已经不复存在了。我们拥有了一个更加碎片化的文化，已经走向了别处。
A sort of, I recognise being modern, national mass culture where people in completely different parts of the country are watching and listening to the same things, sharing the same cultural references, where there is a unified national kind of cultural vocabulary and so on and with something like hollywood you have the same thing so you can you know if you've seen star wars in 1977 everybody else has seen it if you've seen gone with the wind yeah everybody else has seen it that doesn't exist anymore we have a much more fragmented culture that has moved away.
守门人已经消失了。垄断总体上已经消失了。而且我认为也存在一种意识形态上对这种文化的怀疑。所以，我的意思是，无论是《尤利西斯》还是《荒原》，都依赖于人们会认可的共享文化。依赖于经典，因为他们是在与经典对话。依赖于经典。然而现在，“经典”这个概念本身就被视为具有压迫性、霸权主义等等，在那种
The gatekeepers are gone. The monopolies are generally gone. And I think also there's a kind of ideological suspicion of that kind of culture. So, I mean, both Ulysses and the Wasteland depend on a shared culture that people will recognise. On a canon, because they're engaging with a canon. On a canon. Whereas now the very idea of a canon is regarded as oppressive and supremacist and and so on um and in in that
意义上，现代主义与其说是那种经典概念和伟大传统的掘墓人——那条现在被称为“已故的白人欧洲男性”（笑）颁布伟大作品的传统路线的最后辉煌，不如说……是的，我认为这种说法很公平。显然，像BBC这样始于1922年的事物，BBC并不是经典的解毒剂，它绝对是在奉献经典，不断产出经典的各种迭代版本，但现在在2022年，它正被全球文化的碎片化抛在身后。另一件我想说的是，我们所讨论的很多内容都是关于——关于俄国革命、对俄国革命的反应以及共产主义的崛起，关于一场从20世纪20年代初一直贯穿到20世纪80年代末的政治斗争——共产主义与资本主义之间惊天动地的斗争的理念，
sense uh modernism you know is rather than being the the kind of the grave digger of of that idea of a canon and a great tradition and the you know that that line of of what would now be called dead white european males yeah handing out great works is kind of the last hurrah for that tradition yeah i think that's fair to say and obviously you take something like the bbc began in 1922 the bbc is not an antidote to the canon it absolutely enshrines the canon produces endless iterations of it but is now in 2022 being left behind by the fragmentation of of global culture the other thing i suppose i would say is so much of what we talked about is about is about the russian revolution the reaction to the russian revolution and the rise of communism the idea of a struggle a titanic struggle between communism and capitalism that runs right through politics from the early 1920s to the end of the 1980s
然后它几乎就消失了。当然，另一件改变了的事情——同样，我认为这种1922年的现代性确实会终结——是在这期间，我们做了两期节目，没有谈到中国，没有谈到印度，实际上没有谈到中国。没有谈到印度。是的。真的没有谈到日本。
and then disappears pretty much. Well, of course, the other thing that's changed, and again, I think this idea that the modernity of 1922 does kind of end, is that in this, we've done two episodes, haven't talked about China, haven't talked about India, haven't really talked about China. Haven't talked about India. Yeah. Really talked about Japan.
没有谈到非洲。是的。你知道，存在着——我们现在生活的世界，我们可以几乎完全从美国和欧洲的视角来谈论1922年。这可能反映了（你知道的）我们那种狭隘的视角。但我认为并不完全是这样。我认为它反映了这样一个事实：这仍然是一个由欧洲列强和美国构建的世界。而你确实看到日本在远方崛起。但情况已经不再如此了。我们现在生活在一个多极世界中，这对于1922年的人们来说是不可想象的。是的。我想，汤姆，从现在起的一百年后，
Haven't talked about Africa. Yeah. You know, there are, we now live, we can talk about 1922 from an almost exclusively American and European perspective. And that may reflect, you know, the blinkered, our blinkered perspective. But I don't think it does entirely. I think it reflects the fact that this was still a world that was ordered by the European powers and by America. And you do have Japan kind of emerging in the distance. But that's no longer the case. We now live in a multipolar world that would have been unimaginable to people in 1922. Yeah. I suppose, Tom, 100 years from now,
1922年还会显得重要吗？也许不会了，因为关注点已经发生了巨大的变化。是的，我想，汤姆，从现在起的一百年后，1922年还会显得重要吗？也许不会了，因为关注点已经发生了巨大的变化。大英帝国将显得像个如此陈旧的遗迹。乔伊斯和艾略特将不再像现在这样显得是文化上的巨擘。好吧，我甚至不确定他们现在是否还是。我的意思是，我认为尤其是艾略特，正受到高度的怀疑。
will 1922 seem important? Maybe it won't, because the focus will have changed so much. Yeah, I suppose, Tom, a hundred years from now, will 1922 seem important? Maybe it won't, because the focus will have changed so much. The British Empire will seem such a relic. Joyce and Elliot will no longer seem like huge cultural titanic figures in the way that they do now. Well, I'm not sure they even do now. I mean, I think that particularly Elliot is regarded with high suspicion.
1922年会显得重要吗？也许不会，因为焦点已经发生了太大变化。是的，我想，汤姆，从现在起的一百年后，1922年会显得重要吗？也许不会，因为焦点已经发生了太大变化。大英帝国将显得如此像个遗迹。乔伊斯和艾略特也将不再像现在这样显得具有泰坦般的巨大文化影响力。嗯，我不确定他们现在还是不是这样。我的意思是，我认为尤其是艾略特受到了高度的怀疑。
Do you think so? Yes, as a kind of reactionary, conservative and even joyce is he hasn't been cancelled surely he hasn't been cancelled but but you know he's a he's a dead white european male he is it's true so um however i think what will be remembered and rightly what will be rehabilitated is that landmark performance that you talked about at the beginning of the podcast. The one star review. See, I thought we had two stars. No, I'm afraid.
你这么觉得吗？是的，作为一个某种程度上的反动派、保守派，甚至乔伊斯——他还没被取消文化抵制吧？当然没有。但你知道，他是一个死去的白人欧洲男性，确实是的。不过，我认为会被人们铭记、并且理应得到平反的，是你开场时谈到的那个划时代的表现。那个一星差评。等等，我还以为我们有两个星呢。不，恐怕没有。
I'm afraid. You know what? I'm going to post that review on Twitter. I think that review. I'm going to post that review on Twitter so that people can see that I'm not lying. I think your newspaper copy has just faded or something. I'm sure there were two stars. Well, I'll post it and listeners can judge for themselves.
恐怕没有。你知道吗？我要把那个评论发到推特上。我觉得那个评论……我要把它发到推特上，好让大家看看我没撒谎。我觉得你的报纸复印件褪色了什么的。我确信当时有两颗星。好吧，我会发出来的，听众们可以自己评判。
Let's hope. And you know where else I'll post it? I will post it on the Discord chat. Oh, very good. For Restless History Club members. Yes. And I might also post some other things that Rebecca sent. Oh, what?
但愿如此。你知道我还会发在哪里吗？我会发到Discord聊天频道里。哦，非常好。专为《历史闲谈》俱乐部的会员准备的。是的。我还可能会发一些丽贝卡发来的其他东西。哦？是什么？
No, yes. Well, your playbill and your poster and all kinds of things. Do I look good in it? You look fabulous. So I'm going to post that exclusively on the discord so if you want to see this history club i mean i'm worried that's actually a disincentive but actually on the incentive front just one great reminder you will get if you join the rest is history club bonus episodes rest is history pod.com you get bonus episodes you get
不，是的。嗯，你的节目单、海报还有各种各样的东西。我在上面看起来好看吗？你看起来棒极了。所以我会把这些独家发在Discord上，如果你想看这个历史俱乐部的话——我的意思是，我担心这实际上成了一个反向激励。但说到激励，有个很好的提醒：如果你加入《历史闲谈》俱乐部，就可以获得精选的额外单集，网址是 restishistorypod.com。你可以获得额外单集，还可以获得
a live stream you get ad free episodes access to the archive you get all these kind of goodies and if enough people join of course we never need to promote it again on the podcast. And everybody will breathe an enormous sigh of relief. And we're doing our next live episode, we're doing on reputations, aren't we? Yes, on historical reputations. We haven't quite fixed the date for that, but it will be next week or so. And that will be on reputations, how they evolve, how they change, who goes up, who goes down. Yeah.
直播、无广告单集、资料库权限，以及所有这些福利。如果加入的人够多，我们当然就再也不需要在播客里宣传它了。到时候所有人都会长舒一口气。我们要做的下一场直播节目是关于“名誉”的，对吧？是的，关于历史人物的名誉。我们还没完全定下具体日期，但大概就在下周左右。主题就是名誉，它们如何演变、如何改变、谁声名鹊起、谁声名狼藉。是的。
Well, a lot of the people we've talked about on these episodes. Yes, exactly. I mean, Churchill is a classic example. Anyway, we shall deal with this in due course. So thank you so much for listening. Have a very happy 2022. Let's hope it works out rather better for us all than 1922 did. All right.
嗯，我们在这些节目中谈到过很多人。是的，完全如此。我的意思是，丘吉尔就是一个典型的例子。总之，我们会在适当的时候处理这件事。非常感谢大家的收听。祝大家2022年过得愉快。希望对我们所有人来说，这一年能比1922年过得更好。好的。
Bye-bye. Bye-bye. Bye-bye. Thanks for listening to The Rest Is History. For bonus episodes, early access, ad-free listening, and access to our chat community, please sign up at restishistorypod.com. That's restishistorypod.com. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
再见。再见。再见。感谢收听《历史闲谈》。想要收听额外单集、提前收听、无广告体验以及加入我们的聊天社区，请前往 restishistorypod.com 注册。网址是 restishistorypod.com。本集还没有评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。